كن مستعدا فمزاجك قد يتعكر وقلقك قد يزداد
مع قدوم فصل الصيف وربما تتعرض لنوبات
اكتئاب فالحراره العاليه تلعب دورا رئيسيا
في ذلك هذا ما كشفته دراسه حديثه اجراها
خبراء في الصحه العقليه بجامعه
الدراسه خلصت الى ان معدلات الاكتئاب
والقلق لدى البشر معرضه للارتفاع بمجرد
زياده الحراره درجه واحده اكثر من المعتاد
ورغم ان البحث ركز على بنغلاديش الا ان
نتائجه قابله للتطبيق على دول اخرى
فالحراره تؤثر على النقل العصبي
السيروتونين الذي يساهم بتنظيم الحاله
المزاجيه للانسان فمرضى الاكتئاب مثلا
يعانون من صعوبات في عمليه تنظيم الحراري
هذه وبينما يستعد العالم لموجات حراره
جديده تتجدد الحاجه لمعرفه كيفيه حمايه
ادمغتنا من حراره الصيف الحارقه